This video is made possible by audible.
Use My link audible.com forward slash biographics or tax to biographics.
Do 500 500 in the U,
s only to get a free book,
plus you get to audible originals and a 30 day free trial,
so for free.
Just click the link in the description below is the Roku Yamamoto.
Was the mastermind behind the worst attack on American soil ever that doesn't
attack on Pearl Harbor.
Brought war with Japan Bidding Yamamoto against the best military minds of the
US armed forces.
In the end though,
it took a clandestine mid and fascination to bring them to heel and this week's
bind graphics.
We examined the life of a sea rocket Yamamoto.
Yeah.
Well No.
Tony was born as the Roku on April the fourth,
18,
84 in the town of Naga Erica on the island of Honshu.
His father tack our new study.
Yoshi had been involved in an unsuccessful Samurai lead rebellion against the
imperial governments back in 1877.
The government subsequent crackdown on the Samurai made it difficult for to Kano
to find work and he was forced to move all over 100 trying to secure a job.
I've.
You're returning to Naga.
Okay.
His wife died and soon after he married his younger sister in law together,
they had three children.
The youngest of these was this rocky.
The name means 56,
which was his father's age when he was born to Kona.
It was an educated man who,
when he could find a position worked as a school teacher.
He passed his appreciation for knowledge onto his children.
The most gifted of who you see,
rocky.
The boys saw education as the route to breaking the cycle of poverty.
That was his lot in life
in 19.
Oh,
one is Iraq is diligence and application to his studies paid off when he wanted
an appointment to the imperial Navy Academy.
In fact,
his application test score was the second highest in the entire country for the
next three years,
between the ages of 16 and 19,
he lived at the Naval Academy.
You had to at a dream a city near Hiroshima.
In the southern part of Japan,
life of the academy was spotting.
Discipline is a rocky,
were acquitted himself competently,
but it was during the fourth year of the cadetship,
which we spent at sea that he read it again to shine is enabled as quickly
recognized leadership qualities in the man just by only standing at five foot
three inches and weighing around 120 pounds.
He was physically skills being adapted to both gymnastics and the martial arts.
Kendo,
unlike most other students,
he was not interested in drinking and socializing,
but would rather spend his time at reading the Bible and getting a head on his
studies.
In November of 1994 this year,
rocky graduated from the Naval Academy.
Seventh out of 200 since February of that year,
Japan had been at war with Russia,
runs.
See Rocky was immediately thrown right into the fray.
It was assigned to the warship Nisshin on the night of May,
the 26th,
19.
Oh,
five.
The climactic battle of the war began with the Russian Baltic fleet attacking
the Japanese fleet and the Tricia Shima straight.
The mission was one of eight imperial ships presence out of 89 social ships with
more modern ships,
greater speeds,
and better trained crews that Japanese emerged victorious with 21 Russian ships
being sunk and seven being captured.
It was the victory that the Japanese had been desperately needing and it
propelled them to final victory.
However,
versie rocky,
the price for the jury,
it was DB,
one of the gun barrels on board his ship and burst with the shrapnel flying
everywhere he calls up launch piece of metal in the thigh,
and dozens of smaller fragments peppered all throughout his lower body in
addition to have his fingers well hanging by a threat,
he was evacuated to a hospital and did not return to duty until August the
fifth.
Still,
he was recognized for his bravery in this fast test undefined with a letter of
citation and personal commendation from Admiral [inaudible] Togo.
After recovering from his injuries,
this Iraq,
he served on three ships on one of them.
He traveled to the west coast of the United States,
giving him his first American interaction in 19.
Oh,
eight agency rocky completed the basic course at the naval gunnery school going
on to graduate from the advanced course in 1911.
He then spent time on a battleship before attending the Naval Staff College in
Nineteen Thirteen and see rocky excelled in staff training being Mr x by his
Tutus as a man on the rise.
Following his graduation in 1916,
he was appointed to the second battle squadron as a leftenant commander.
It was around this time that Tacoma is Iraq,
became Yamamoto is rocky with both his parents having died in 1912 and having
older brothers,
it was clear that this Iraqi would never come to head the Chicano plan.
Yeah,
so the Yamamoto cannon was in need of a new mail APP.
The clams saw the rising young naval officer as the perfect fit.
This is what I'm saying,
a man into a family in order to serve as the male.
There was quite a common practice and it was accepted by us,
the rocky,
however it required that he find a wife and two sons do continue the Yamamoto
name.
It was at the age of 34.
Then in 1918,
the TC Roku entered into an arranged marriage the few months later in 1919,
he was assigned to the United States do take up an assignment as a naval
representative.
He spends a month at Harvard University studying the English language event,
continued to study independently to master English while also learning all he
could about the oil industry,
which was vital to the operation of an efficient navy while in the USC also
picks up a penchant for gambling which he proved to be quite successful.
In fact,
he took a tour of Mexican oil fields which was partly financed from his gambling
proceeds in 1921 and see rocky returned to Japan where he received a posting,
an instructor at the Naval Staff College.
Over the five years of his service.
In this capacity,
he deepened his knowledge of oil while also developing a fascination with
aviation.
In 1926,
he was assigned to the United States for a second time where he stayed for two
years as he rocky's two great passions combined in 1928 when he was given
command of the Imperial Navy's first aircraft carrier ecology.
He retains this post for a little over a year.
Within that time,
he developed a strong bonds with the men under his command z grit.
The tomorrow they're strict,
but Faq Monda.
Let's see.
Rocky was mastery of the English language,
made him a valuable asset to the Japanese high command,
and in October of 1929,
he was stationed to London to act as an assistant to the Japanese delegation to
the London Naval Conference of Nineteen 30.
During his time in London,
he received the news that he had been promoted to rear admiral back in Japan.
Yamamoto was given yet another role within the imperial navy.
He became head of the technical division of the aeronautics department.
After three years,
he then found himself back in command to the economy.
He threw himself into this role,
disciplining and training as aviators with absolute precision.
However,
eight months into this role,
he was again selected for service overseas.
The preliminary discussions for the second London naval conference took place in
London in October of 1934 and the gamma motor was selected as a chief delegate.
He was tasked with pressing Japan's claim for a better naval construction ratio,
which had previously been set at 60 percent of the battleship and carrier
strength of the United States and Britain.
Despite his own personal misgivings,
he proved to be the right man for the job.
His opposition negotiators from Britain and the US were impressed with his
intelligence and his reasonableness.
He put the demands from his government on the table which worth and naval parity
with the other two powers.
This was never going to be acceptable to the Brits and the Americans and
Yamamoto.
He knew this,
the negotiations.
They went nowhere and the conference broke up without resolution even though we
had not been able to achieve as government's ambitions.
Yamamotos prominence at the conference had made in internationally famous.
When he returned to Japan,
he faced a period of stagnation which was very troubling to him.
In fact,
he seriously considered at this point,
resigning from the navy.
Fun Kit was resolved though in December of 1935 when he was appointed chief of
the aeronautics department at the Navy Ministry.
He was now the boss of everything to do with naval aviation in Japan.
This gave him the ability to put into development some of the concepts that he
had previously worked on.
These included the type 96 land based attack plane.
This one's the most advanced attack plane possessed by any navy in the world and
would form a central part of Yamamotos offensive plans against the United
States.
Now,
on February the 26th,
19,
36,
there was an attempted military coup in Japan.
The nationalistic governments placed Admiral Magonia Sama.
Whereas the new minister of the Navy Yamamoto excepted the position of vice
navy,
Minnesota.
He sat about reinstilling,
a lost discipline and the navy's command dismissing those who didn't meet the
standards.
He also actively worked to prevent the army's push towards war.
Nineteen 37 was to prove to be a key,
uh,
in the advancement of Japan's war stance in the wake of starting a war on her
doorstep with China.
She signed a tripartite pact with Germany and definitely yellow.
Jay was against the pact and he wasn't shy about voicing his opinion.
This brought him into increasing conflicts with the army administration and
their right wing followers.
He received numerous death threats.
These didn't phase him and he appears to have accepted that sooner or later he
would simply be assassinated.
A crisis occurred in 1939.
This was when the Germans signs a nonaggression pact with Russia,
the traditional enemies of the Japanese.
On August the 23rd,
the entire Japanese cabinet resigned,
resulting in Yamamotos loss of his position as vice navy minister along with his
Superior Navy Minister Uni before leaving office.
However,
you know I had appointed Yamamoto as the commander in chief of the combined
imperial fleet.
Yamamoto was a highly experienced commander and to get the respect of his men,
he was seen as a pacifist at a time when the country was marching towards war.
However,
he threw himself into the position with his usual Gusto,
pushing aside his own reservations and stepping up training and preparation for
the coming conflict.
By the end of 1940,
the pro German factions within the armed forces were driving the country towards
a conflict with the United States,
though personally opposed to taking on the use.
I'm the moto began planning for succession eventuality.
He was adamant that the only chance for success against America laying with a
massive surprise attack that would take out the American fleet,
followed up by the blitzkrieg like tactics that the Germans were using with such
positive effects in Europe.
It repeatedly stated that if a wall was to be one against the United States,
it had to be completed within six months.
Otherwise,
the economic and manpower advantage of the Americans would inevitably prevailed.
In July 19,
41,
the United States responded to continue Japanese aggression in China by imposing
a trade embargo on Japan and freezing all Japanese assets in its country,
Britain and the Netherlands.
They quickly followed suit.
The most crippling effect was the loss of oil imports,
which accounted for 90 percent of Japan's usage and of course the largest user
of oil and the country was Japan's imperial navy.
The Japanese response was to further step up preparation for war while also
looking to seize control of the oil reserves held in the Dutch east indies and
the British had in the Far East.
Yamamoto believed that any attack on or British possessions withdraw the
Americans into an armed conflict.
It was at this time that Yamamoto formulated the plan for a decisive preemptive
strike on the American naval base at Pearl Harbor in Hawaii.
He believed that such a crushing blow would destroy American morale and lead to
a negotiated peace settlement.
The plan was risky and many officials were opposed to it.
It's big volumes about Yamamoto is prestige and influence that he was able to
push the plan through to a final approval.
The plan was actually rejected by the navy general staff several times,
but finally I'm a moto.
Had to put his foot down as long as he was commander in chief.
He called his command is the Pearl Harbor attack.
We'd go ahead.
He then went to the naval general staff and told them that unless the plan was
approved,
he and his entire staff would resign.
The idea of going to war with out Yamamoto was a scary prospect to the navy bras
and they finally relented.
Yamamoto is planned for Pearl Harbor,
was to sink as many battleships as possible.
He sold the battleship as the symbol of American naval superiority and figured
that the sudden loss of the majority of that reserve would destroy the American
fighting spirit.
However,
staff officer for the first athletes,
[inaudible] Granada,
I felt that it was more advantageous do concentrate on singing American aircraft
carriers.
In the end,
a compromise was reached.
The first wave of the attack comprising of 40 torpedo planes would be directed
at two carriers.
The other 24 planes would focus on the eight battleships.
That could also potentially be that another 50 level Bowman's web to head for
battleship row where most of that or ships were expected to be buffed.
Meanwhile,
54 dive bombers were the escorting fighters were to attack the oil fields on a
Awahoo who the second wave of the attack was to comprise 81 dive bombers and was
intended to finish off the cruisers with their bombs being too small to damage
the battleships.
As it turned down to the attack during the early hours of December,
the seventh,
19,
41 was far more successful and it's targeting of battleships,
cruises,
none of which were actually in the doc that day.
The battleships so in West Virginia was sunk while the California was struck
with two torpedoes eventually sinking and the Nevada with a single strike that
also brought her down.
All of this was achieved in only 11 minutes in battleship row.
The Arizona was struck with a 1,760 pounds armor piercing,
bombed the forward magazine of the ship,
exploded,
killing 1000,
177 offices and creaming the attack was a complete success.
Achieving Yamamotos objective of decimating American naval power in one fell
sweep.
18 ships had been sunk or damaged while only 29 Japanese aircraft had been shot
down.
Most pleasing dmr motor was that five battleships that either sunk or beached in
the bigger picture of things.
However,
the attack at Pearl Harbor it achieved little yamamoto is emphasis on destroying
battleships.
It was not a sound policy.
The Americans were already moving towards carriers rather than battleships and
the Pearl Harbor attack merely sped up.
This transition further more than rather than breaking American morale is
Yamamoto had thought that the attack served as a rallying cry to drive the
American zone.
Two final victory
with the United States Declaration of war against Japan on December the eighth,
19,
41.
The Japanese had to devise a strategy to overcome this far greater power.
It was decided to fight a defensive campaign where the Americans would be drawn
into the Pacific eastern,
worn down to the point of accepting a negotiated peace settlement.
Meanwhile,
the Japanese would occupy key territories in the Asia Pacific moving down into
Australasia or in the central Pacific,
Yemen military believe that when Singapore was taken,
the time would be right to sue for peace with the success of his brainchild,
the Pearl Harbor Attack Yamamotos influence group.
He was instrumental in planning invasions on Malaysia and the Philippines as
well as Guam in Singapore.
In early February of 1942,
he moved his staff headquarters onto the super battleship yamato with Singapore
having fallen.
Yamamoto believed that it was time for his government to pressure the allies for
peace.
It's lack of action on this greatly frustrated him despite his conviction that
our campaign that went for more than six months would be disastrous.
He was forced to plan out the next phase of the war.
However,
his ideas were at odds with the naval general staff who wanted to concentrate on
Australia where he was intent on taking control of the Indian subcontinent.
The army,
however,
refused to back such a plan and it was quickly taken off the table.
The first major setback for the Japanese,
the code with the battle of coral sea between may the fourth and the eighth,
1942,
which successfully hold to the Japanese invasion of New Guinea.
Yeah,
million.
So we continue to butt heads with the naval general stuff as he now proposed an
attack on Midway atoll that would draw out the remnants of the American fleet
from Hawaii.
Wires could be utterly destroyed.
Resistance was stiff with general staff members pointing out the midway was too
close to Pearl Harbor and too far away from Japan.
You have a motorcycle now used his old tactic of threatening to resign and you
go his way again.
The attack on midway required Yamamoto,
two coordinators,
fleets over huge stretches of water.
Yeah,
Moto,
but board.
The Yamato personally led one battle group and self.
What he didn't know was that the Americans had broken their secret codes and
we're already aware of the attack and advance through us.
Carriers were sent to midway in order to surprise the Japanese.
In the ensuing battle,
four Japanese carriers were sent to the bottom of the ocean acknowledging
defeat.
Yamamoto ordered his remaining ships back to base the defeat at midway,
was a humiliation for Yamamoto and see received much criticism for us still,
he was able to retain his position as commander chief,
largely because to remove in would have been too demoralizing for the men under
his command.
Over the next few months,
the Japanese achieved limited success against the fleet around Guata canal in
the Solomon Islands.
The Battle of Guadalcanal,
however,
was another crushing defeat for the Japanese
in the wake of Guadalcanal.
Yamamoto set out on a morale boosting tour of af four spaces across the South
Pacific on April the 14th,
1943 and message which announced his exact itinerary on route to a base in the
Solomon Islands was intercepted by US intelligence.
This presented the Americans with the perfect opportunity,
do assassinate the Japanese naval commander in chief.
It was a risk and that it would portray the Americans' ability to break Japanese
code,
but Yamamoto was seen as such a big fish that it was deemed worth giving up.
This intelligence,
a plan,
nicknames operation.
Vengeance was put into operation with the objective of killing Yamamoto.
18 US fighter pilots were chosen from the base at Guadalcanal to participate in
the operation.
14 of them would provide cover at around 20,000 feet while for others for them
to a strikeforce to blow yamamotos plane right out of the sky.
The attack it was set for April the 18th that morning that was not one but two
m,
one type one betty bombers along with six a six,
seven,
zero five just to provide escort and yamamotos fleet.
It wasn't long into the flight when the four American p 38 swept seen
approaching the bomber that was carrying Emma Moto immediately began to descend
while the escort planes moved into intercept,
the Americans bombed so they weren't able to prevent the [inaudible] from
achieving their objectives.
With both of the betty bombers receiving strikes,
both of the planes crashed.
However,
an autopsy on his body revealed that Yamamoto who was sitting on the starboard
side of the plane behind the plane commander had been struck by bullets to the
drawer and shoulder and was probably dead before the plane hit the grounds.
Yamamotos body was found later that day.
It had been thrown from the wreckage,
still strapped to the seat.
The death of Yamamoto was not revealed to the Japanese people until may the 20,
fast more than a month after he was shot down,
more than a million people lined the streets of Tokyo as his ashes passed by.
So today's video was made possible by audible,
who I'm sure many of you know about already.
I've been a longtime customer of audible reading tons of books on all sorts of
subjects.
In fact,
it's kind of a funny story.
I personally really love autobiographies and biographies and listening to those
three audible.
I was actually inspired me to stop this channel.
No kidding.
It all kind of came full circle,
so thanks for that order bulk.
There are loads of autobiographies on audible and I bet that if it's a notable
book,
there's going to be a cool audiobook version of it as well.
Also related to this video,
there are tons of audio books on World War Two,
the Pacific theater,
Pearl Harbor itself.
Lots and lots of those.
I just did a quick search and the entire first page of results are all super
highly rated books about this attack and its consequences.
Now,
what about was always a good deal and you'd go into an audio book a month for a
low fee,
but now there's even more.
In addition them is get to audible originals every single month in addition to
their book of choice.
These are from some of the world's most celebrated storytellers,
journalists,
novelists,
and many others.
There's plenty to choose from.
There's also fitness and health workouts for members,
so horrible was always great,
but now there's even more if you've been putting off,
signing up for it to do so.
No longer go search Pearl Harbor in order bowl and grab something that takes
your fancy.
There's loads of great reviewed books,
like I say,
just go to audible.com forward slash biographics.
This also a link in the description below.
Doing that also helps support this show and helps us keep more biographics
videos coming your way.
Again,
get started with a free book now with a 30 day free trial@audible.com forward
slash biographics,
or if you're in America tax to biographics do 500,
500.
So I really hope you found this video interesting.
If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below and don't forget to subscribe for
brand new videos twice a week.
So hit that subscribe button,
hit that bell button.
If you really want to get notifications,
and as always,
thank you for watching.